[Music]
you believe passionately uh that
legalizing cannabis you don't like to
say marijuana you think it's a little
divisive like you just say cannabis the
medical term you believe legalizing
cannabis and taxing it
like alcohol would actually help us the
united states get out of the debt crisis
that we're in right now do you believe
that seriously i really do there's
precedent for it um before alcohol
prohibition
sometimes at times 70 percent of u.s
federal revenue came from alcohol for
better or for worse so uh we could see
the same thing with cannabis plus the
drug wars
40 years in trillion dollars of our tax
money and i mean
as far as affecting supply
let's just look at this audience it's
like a willie nelson tour bus out here
so
that's not
it's not really true only about four
people in the audience responded to that
everyone else is on something else
i get more of a pill crowd um
but this is interesting you think the
amounts of money that you think are
involved here are enormous we're talking
about enormous revenue could be
generated revenue that would that would
change the stakes for the united states
fiscally oh yeah um so i looked at one
particular county that basically just
called it off declared the drug war done
mendocino county northern california
mendocino right they just admitted what
was already there and america continued
and they raised six hundred thousand
dollars in one year and so what did they
do explain how it worked what mendocino
did is the the local sheriff just on his
own pretty much said you know what we're
not gonna fight this anymore we're gonna
control it the board of supervisors
passed a law that the sheriff endorsed
as a way of raising revenue in a in a
fiscally strapped county and they saved
seven jobs and six billion dollars is
the estimated annual
revenue from the county um from this
crop it's also america's number one cash
crop but in this county the legal crop
it's america's number one cash crop more
than corn and soy combined so let's get
that into the tax base
you're saying that i i can't believe
that it's more than corn and soy
combined it it really is yeah and that's
you know before anybody can grow it
openly
so
in mexico i know this is all real what
if you're just high right now
i did more than there are stars in the
sky
are you sure yeah i'm sure
no there's no place to get in la anymore
right exactly that's over uh
well let's talk about this uh i've
always assumed uh and i'm a bit of a
square i'll admit that but i've always
assumed that uh drug cartels gangs that
that pot
that they were that was more about
cocaine that that's where the real
revenue was from you say that legalizing
marijuana would vastly affect the
cartels and the gangs yeah some of the
estimates put as high as 70 of cartel
revenues are coming from cannabis and so
um knock that out and transfer that to
the legitimate american economy put
farmers back into the fields um it could
be it could truly be a real boon to the
economy for sure okay uh so you're
saying overnight the drug cartels would
be immobilized practically you know i
don't know about overnight it's kind of
hard to prognosticate but if you look at
history and alcohol prohibition there's
not so many bootleggers anymore you know
yeah it's true and when there are you
just feel sorry for them
we're gonna have some whiskey
i was surprised
underground come join me
this is not a right-wing left-wing issue
there are a lot of people who hear about
this might assume that well you know
conservatives
republicans must be against this or
democrats must be foreign that it would
divide along those lines you're you're
saying it does not really divide along
those lines that's probably been the
most surprising thing is i'm you know i
live in the heartland i've got a ranch
in new mexico and i'm running into
grannies and cowboy hats in the market
and tell them what my book's about and i
just progressively i'm getting less and
less sort of you know apologetic about
it you know you tell people
you know makes sense for america
economically to end this drug war and
everybody everybody that i run into is
into it and we've got pat robertson
speaking out against the drug war now
too so evangelicals are coming on so
evangelicals are saying legalize
cannabis big time yeah okay